le prince igor est une grande épopée
russe est l'unique opéra d'alexandre
borodine un opéra ballet où évolue un
jeune vie si noah christophe ouest ça
faisait un moment que j'avais plus envie
de me diriger vers plus l'aspect
compagnie
c'est une manière différente de
travailler ça ça m'attirait plus en plus
donc j'ai essayé cette audition c'était
pour l'opéra quoi c'est une scène
magnifique c'est l'opéra de paris c'est
une grande institution de la danse donc
ouais c'est un c'était une vraie envie
pour moi d'essayer de faire ce spectacle
la danse une passion arrivé sur le tard
le jeune homme la découvre à l'âge de 13
ans le hip hop avec la compagnie
chinoise illicites dance une simple
activité extrascolaire avant le déclic
c'est à proposer un stage de danse un
peu intensif pour préparer un spectacle
qui a l'espoir en pologne
c'était dans le cadre du jumelage de la
ville de voisins et de la ville de louga
en pologne est donc là ça a été une
semaine on a créé vraiment tout un
spectacle de façon assez intensive tous
les jours et c'est là où j'ai eu plus le
déclic et je me suis dit que moi ça me
plaisait quoi
[Musique]
pour mémoire
tout de suite très travailleur très très
très travailleur et est organisé ce qui
n'est pas le cas des des gamins de son
âge
donc on doit un peu cadré mais lui tout
de suite très organisée donc commence à
se profiler on se disait on il ya
quelque chose à faire avec ce jeune
homme un soutien qui l'emmène vite au
professionnalisme un premier goût avec
la mini team d'illicite il se forme
ensuite à cergy en horaires aménagés de
licence staps sciences et techniques des
activités physiques et sportives
j'ai commencé par par le hip hop parce
que c'est aussi ce que je voyais de la
danse qui me plaisait de par les films
de danse que je pouvais voir les clips
avec les artistes les concerts et puis
après plus il ya eu de travail dans la
danse et plus j'essaie de prendre
d'autres styles bondues contemporain du
classiers différents styles qui lui
permettent de multiplier les expériences
danse avec les stars auprès de shy'm
elle aussi formé à vichy dance les dix
commandements la comédie musicale
chorégraphié par kamel ouali ou encore
avec soprano pour la fête de la musique
[Musique]
aujourd'hui encore il revient illicites
quand il n'est pas sur scène il est en
atelier chorégraphique
un retour aux sources où il forme à son
tour des passionnés depuis quatre ans
c'est un artiste donc forcément ils
exigent mais il prend bien le temps
d'expliquer ce qui sait très bien que
quand on a des débutants eux mêmes
décors inter c'est pareil il faut
prendre il faut vraiment prendre le
temps de détailler et de bien expliquer
que c'est normal de pouvoir la cour est
tout de suite très patient toujours à l
écoute et vraiment il donne toujours de
très bon conseil
c'est très important que si on écoute
suffisamment on progresse assez vite
âgé de 25 ans il est actuellement sur la
scène de l'opéra bastille à paris le
prince igor se joue jusqu'au 26 décembre